you
hello everyone
we're having some kind of technical
problem I hope everybody can see me and
hear me I don't know what's going on but
looks like every two to five minutes
transmission gets cut off on in on the
internet I lose contact with a server
and only on this computer so I have no
idea what's going on we try to figure
out we still haven't been able to but if
we get cut off I'm just gonna reset and
continue so just be aware that there
could be some interruptions okay anyways
we were dealing with a couple issues
philosophy irrationality and quantum
mechanics and they kind of all go
together there they're all related it's
like you can't separate one way from the
other the issue with philosophy is that
we have no definitions today no formal
definition of what philosophy is and the
main reason for that is that philosophy
is defined in terms of knowledge truth
and who knows what else and when you
look up the word knowledge it's not it's
undefined it's still undefined to this
day after 2,000 years the most popular
definition on you could say the
scientific definition I don't know if
that's a valid way of putting it is
plato's definition justified true belief
in other words knowledge is a belief
which is pretty much right in my opinion
because there is no such thing as
knowledge knowledge I define as the
ability to run an experiment and predict
the results of an experiment without a
shadow of doubt and you can't do that
you can't predict the future without a
shadow of a doubt at least that's my
point
my my position so my point here is that
the word knowledge has no bearing
whatsoever on science even though the
word science comes from cita
which is the Latin
2,000 years ago the Latin version of
knowledge science has nothing to do with
knowledge and assuming we could even
define knowledge right but the point
here is that science is about
explanations and not about knowledge and
now and explanations have to do with the
past you can only explain a consummated
event on the other hand knowledge has to
do with the future and the best example
I can give you for that is you know we
in in ordinary speech we say oh I know
that Julius Caesar went to England with
his troops well what do you mean you
know someone told you and you believed
it and you memorize it for the test
whatever but you can't run an experiment
you can't reproduce the observation
again to prove to me or to prove to
yourself and prove to the world that
your knowledge is correct
I can't reproduce a consummated event
this is one of the things that could
have happened it's not that I'm saying I
know that this is the one that happened
it's I know this is a possibility yeah
yeah and again wouldn't that be a
version of knowing well again knowing is
what do we say belief was belief says
believe is religion right and opinion is
religion what are we saying here we're
saying that out of the possibilities
which I came up with yesterday which I
thought was pretty good objective versus
subjective subjective means you're gonna
choose one that's okay objective means
you've got all these possibilities okay
and that's quite objective and you could
and you could propose one more which is
what I'm doing for example with a rope
model I'm saying look you guys missed
one here let me put that one in there
that's also objective because I'm not
trying to convince you I'm just saying
you forgot what your brainstorm we're
still breaks basically the verb for
objective
for the objective part is brainstorming
all the verb for subjective is choosing
right and so what what we're doing when
we're going into religion when we're
going into opinion when we're going into
belief knowledge which is justified true
belief is we're saying I'm gonna choose
this one but maybe not true the same
thing for truth but that's my point
maybe it's not because maybe knowledge
as opposed to believe could be the
brainstorming part where you're just
brainstorming all the assumptions and
combinations of assumptions to get to
the bottom of something like trying to
explain magnets right okay
knowledge would basically be in that
case at least it could be in this case
what are all the ways to explain
magnetism
that's knowledge yeah but the objective
belief basically yeah but again then we
would have to find out what the
definition of the word knowledge is and
if you find the word knowledge in terms
of the word belief then then we're back
to religion you know knowledge has no
place in science and well anyways those
are questions of definitions of how we
use these words in science and whether
they belong to religion and I'm saying
knowledge belongs to religion has
nothing at all to do with sign yes I
would say that knowledge belongs to
science because it's the brainstorming
part is the objective part well then you
would have to define the word yeah it
would basically be homework
everyone knows the notion or it's it's
not the choosing part that's that's the
subjective that's the belief right well
knowledge is all the possibilities of
any given question or any given
situation but you know a word knowledge
has never is not used in that way even
under ordinary speech and people say I
know they're concentrating not yeah
they're already picking one it's the
belief the belief version not the brain
but when you're talking about general
knowledge like what is the human
knowledge because that's also the way
it's used in philosophy often okay where
people say okay what do
what do we know what yeah yeah yeah then
is there more talking about all the
possibilities of any given question or
yeah but then what you do in those cases
is you you're not dealing with one
specific subject you're dealing like oh
this is the BA nobody could know all the
properties basically brainstorming all
the properties of air
you're not saying I guess you aren't
choosing because you're getting at the
property think you can reconcile
knowledge with brainstorm because it is
brainstorming because you're not
choosing you're just brainstorming
everything that is yeah but then it's
the word now this fits awkwardly with
that good you know anyways the point
that I was on the difference between
brainstorming and believing and knowing
well again when we do when we're
brainstorming real specific you're just
throwing things in there that which
could be things which are not under
knowledge for example I can even
brainstorm for example write that one of
the things that causes the orbit of the
earth are angels that they move the
earth around and you say well you know
should we include that in there well
yeah it's part of the brainstorming
process does that mean we know that
there are angels do we know for sure
that space is warped do we know for sure
you know that there is negative momentum
transfer in quantum mechanics which is
the way they kind of explained you know
attraction you know it's not that we
know it's if you're just gonna
brainstorm and say look these are all
the things I can think of I don't think
you can say that's knowledge knowledge
is when you select one of those then it
makes sense to use the word knowledge in
at least in ordinary speech and say I
know I know that angels push the earth
around the Sun now you know now you no
longer are brainstorming you're not
saying you're not even comparing you're
just saying I've already selected one
what is the process of brainstorming
because it doesn't have to have two or
more people could just be by yourself
yeah what's your process of
brainstorming well it's just coming up
with ideas that try and imagine all the
situations possible even outlandish ones
you know things that have no chance
whatsoever you you might even brainstorm
those but you know if you if you do like
put angels for gravity and you say well
you know I I don't believe and I don't
think angels move but I got included
under the brainstorming list just to
cover that base then I don't know I
don't know you can call that knowledge a
crime scene when he brainstorms he has
to list out objectively speaking
obviously he's not picking one yet but
he kind of is that's my point this
there's a there's a tricky thing it's
everything that you can think of yeah
mr. Watson it's as objective Sherlock
Holmes would do that to mr. woo it's not
objective because objective would be
like purely objective would be all the
possibilities but what really happens in
brainstorming is this there's this human
error
it goes in because it's everything you
can think of yeah but again that's why I
can't see how brainstorming would be
related to knowledge brains Tommy again
knowledge no nobody did yeah okay okay
but but I'm saying is again we're trying
to really deal with the word now I
change the topic okay forget knowledge
I'm trying to figure out if
brainstorming is actually objective
because what it is it is objective the
way we use objective where you're just
who are you just trying to figure out
something and you're not trying to
believe yeah believe you're not choosing
yet it's kind of like a blend of both
because you can't put in um you could
put in angels you killed this person I
know but you could offer that base why
don't you leave no but you're doing your
detective
what would rule out angels 100% yeah but
you ruled it out app you ruled it out
after brainstorming no they never even
think of angels well I don't they think
that they themselves did I think that's
I think that's wrong not to brainstorm
angels I think you should brainstorm
angels whether you believe in them or
not is a secondary issue but I think you
you have to brainstorm and say you know
I covered that base just to cover the
base AuSable because you can't
brainstorm all the possibilities well as
many as come to your mind I'll just
point you never cover all the bases my
way don't you're already sifting while
your brain sauna it's like you kind of
just just think within the realm of what
you think it could be well there's so
that's what I'm talking about about lack
of imagination where because that's how
it happens with with theoretical
physicists where they don't they never
even pondered the role hypothesis let's
put it more clearly
they never pondered torsion I mean you
have longitudinal waves in fact that's
in the real physics video of today you
have longitudinal waves you have
transverse waves and and if you look
throughout the internet you won't find
analysis of torsion ways it's like
nobody even thought about that that's my
point it's like so they missed up a big
one that they missed you can brainstorm
but still miss something so the
objective part is like I said the
objective as you can get everyone's got
a limit to how objective they can get
because they just can't think like
forget about picking they just can't
think of more possibilities you know
like like a detective could see a crime
scene and think of nine possibilities
but it happens to be the tenth one yeah
yeah yeah but let me say something about
that you know at AMD where I worked for
many years we had quality circles and
those quality quality circles an idea I
guess that began in Japan anyways they
implemented that at AMD and it worked
pretty good we had all these groups
maybe I think they never exceeded ten
people and you had operators technicians
engineers supervisor everybody was in
there you had
presented it from different parts of the
organization of different segments and
what the quality circles did they
started out with brainstorming that was
a number dos first step and so you know
the engineer he comes up and he proposes
things from his angle you know I've got
a spec to write this what I'm thinking
about this is what I know about the
process this would I recommend this is
what I think should happen this is what
I think is happening and then the
operator said well you know I'm on the
line I got to work with this machine
every day and this is a problem I've got
supervisor has a different focus he says
you know I gotta get production out you
know time is money and managers on top
of me saying you know get those things
out and goes those wafers out and the
product out and so everybody's got a
different interest and that's part of
the brainstorming process because you
did begin with brainstorming you got a
problem on the line you say how do we
solve it okay everybody comes with a
different angle this is the operator
this is the technician this is the
maintenance guy who's got to fix the
machine because they need a solution
that covers all the bases yeah and so
brainstorming should be more you know
for it to be really productive it should
be more than one person it really helps
in fact here with my son you can see
that you know you I don't always think
of everything that I'm supposed to think
about and he comes somebody said oh how
about this and he comes up with new
stuff okay two heads are better than one
three are better than two and so on you
know and so brainstorming returns some
point you fight more than what you
propose but the point is that you know
brainstorming is is a good start it's
good to have brainstorming Ness that's
good but then you know and then and then
you should put everything on the table
even angels you should put a noose on
you bring up angels at the end no we
didn't know no but if said no but
sometimes you know we Yui we're a little
facetious and probably we were shooting
the ball at some point in time and no
problem you know someone would propose
something outlandish something out of
this world we'd say
okay let's put it on the board we would
put it on the board and immediately
scratch say well we covered that base
right so you know it's because it's not
completely clean in the sense that yeah
you can bring some without without bias
but there's implicit bias because your
mind can only imagine so many things for
example someone who's never who's never
heard of human flight right right that's
one less bag in his back yeah but he can
bring in shirts he might say well you
know like you can get it pygmy from the
jungles and say look this is flight and
you say well I've never seen a human fly
I don't know what an airplane is but
I've seen birds fly you know and so he
might talk you might propose something
that birds that you never thought about
because you don't know bizarre burst but
that's my point everyone's got their own
tank their own I don't want to go
subjective because still brainstorming
still it's still looking for an answer
without bias but it's that weird you
know cultural bias or upbringing bias
where it's like a person can only think
of what they've been raised to think
about yeah something like that
but nothing wrong with that as long as
again if you have several people on with
different backgrounds then you get a
good brainstorming sessions that's the
points to overcome your education on
biases or shortcomings let's say you
kind of have to do with more people
because the more people the more the
merrier the more of the of the of the
pie that mother nature knows is covered
yeah one person can only cover so much
but there are another you have two
people okay they live two different
lives they have two different
educational backgrounds so they have
different answers but education plays a
big role in that because we have all
these physicists who all had the same
education so they're all just keep
cutting out the same piece of the pie
and that's not and they're not leaving
the and that is a serious product
because at the box because they're all
brainwashed in the same way when they go
to college you know the assembly line
you know conveyer building which they
all sit you know they're all processing
the same way and and that creates a
certain uniformity across the board
which is very bad for science and for
brainstorming because they all
brainstorm within the sandbox
yeah yeah they don't think out of the
box I think that goes to what you said
about angels where you have to always
consider angels yeah just because it's
out of the box you have to consider
things out of the box that you kind of
offhandedly I mean sometimes when we're
debating in the kitchen one of us will
say just because we're trying to get to
the bottom something will say something
outlandish just just just to go down
that route yeah to cover that base or to
cheat or to think out of the box for a
second yeah he's even though it's it's a
you know unlikely the first let's make
sure we're let make sure we can reject
that possibility little brains you take
it in on a tangent and and you go all
the way to the end of the cul-de-sac to
make sure that you covered that you know
that angle if you think about it that's
the that's the best form of
brainstorming because we both kind of
understand things that we both
understand like yeah both have okay we
have these things down and we both kind
of are still unsure about some question
right yeah so so we both have to go
outside of what we both know we kind of
have to think outside the box well yeah
I mean that's kind of the when you're
trying to figure something out for
yourself by definition you have to think
outside the box because it's not in your
box yeah whatever whatever answer you're
looking for you don't have it yet yeah
yeah and and that's the way it should
work you know and and again one of the
things that you have to look at is that
you know when you get people together
and a brainstorm they do a much better
job than just of one person unless all
of them are came out of the same cookie
cutter yeah and that's the issue with
mathematics mathematics all these people
come out out of college with the same
cookie cutter and that's where the
problem is that's
tie scientific it's you know completely
non-scientific with school in general
yeah the kind of chanting on through a
tunnel it's good and bad it's good for
for philosophy is good for living how to
live but it's bad for science because
the kids aren't trying to come up with
answers on their own they're you fed the
answers right memorize which is good
because you just need the what's the
right answer to live the right way I
need but that's I think I need that to
pass the test you need math for example
likely to do your bills or to make you
know the no ratio yeah yeah so they give
you this cookie cutter um you know
formula for example how to calculate
something which you might need to do
your taxes for gavel or something yeah
but it's not that it's that's different
than doing science because they're
you're just learning something by rote
you're learning it Creed in that sense
the way I use the word you're just used
learning a tool that you can use later
on well science would be more let's ask
a question even if even if the teacher
knows the answer right science would be
asking the question and just letting the
students figure it out that's the
science part but what do you call the
teacher just giving people the answer
yeah and again unfortunately much of
school much of school is just memorizing
and yes that's what you're that's what
you're referring to I mean history a lot
of that is memorizing and again you know
I included under philosophy but what do
I include explanations if you can
explain you know why this guy did this
why that King did that then it's good
but if you just memorize dates and say
there was a battle in such as in such
state all you did was memorize you know
can you say that you know that you know
that happened no you just memorize it
for the test and maybe you still
remember it for the rest of your life
for all I know but it but you know again
it's not it's not there that science
vibrates science vibrates when you have
to explain something why the cause or
reason in this case
it's interesting because many people
have that same type like many TED talks
are about the failures of Education and
they always because to me education or
school is to is twofold as two purposes
one is to teach you tools by rote
memorization that you'll need to that
you'll need in life like writing
these things you don't have to think
about that's the one is the one that
ever it has a gripe with which is school
is there to teach you how to learn it's
there to teach you how to teach yourself
basically it's learn is there to teach
you how to think how to how to do
critical thinking it's a skill that it's
supposed to teach you but school kind of
left that by the wayside and stuck to
the road to the memorizing I can give
you two examples which show the
difference between what we do in schools
today and how it's supposed to be not
supposed to well how it's supposed to be
in order for you to use your brain which
is which is essentially what we're
asking people to do to use their brains
and it's not easy for a lot of people
people would rather say just give me the
answer and I'll memorize it and we're
done
no no you got to think about it here's
where it goes
Socrates he got in he would discuss with
his students Plato you know casino fond
and so on he had all these people around
them and they would debate a question
would pop up and they would argue over
that and then you know the student that
younger people said well this is my
intuition just what I think and that's
what Socrates used his experience and
say well you know how about this and
they waited to these dialogues and so on
and that's how they learn and I thought
that was a very good way of learning
because they exchanged ideas and the
other example that I have is the Jews
you know the Jews as I understand it you
know they sit one across from another on
a table and they look at a paragraph or
a verse in the Bible in the Old
Testament you know the
the the the part that deals with the
Jewish history and so on
and they start debating over that and
they exchange ideas with just one on one
and there's another pair here another
pair over there they're on a long table
and they discuss across from each other
and they argue they argue and even
better than that there's a crowd like
little smaller kids who don't really
know how to argue they're watching
people argue so they're kind of learning
oh yeah and the issue here is that
sometimes you got to play just devil's
advocate well what if you know and and
that's good because then people have to
think how I learn but everybody but if
people just memorize what you know what
everybody already found out what we know
we just memorize what we know well then
you know then all you're doing is just
the absorbing you know what is that is
that science is that dying is that
education it is because like I said it's
twofold you have to learn how to write
yeah those things yeah I'm talking about
explanation that's my point there's two
things to education you have to learn
the tools and you have to learn how to
think yeah and the thinking part is
where people are failing because people
are just accepting what the
mathematicians are feeding them without
understanding you know a lot of the
foundations for those reasonings for
those for the reasons for why they came
up with this stuff because a lot of that
is high level math and they say well
from here we extrapolated these ideas
and people say well I don't care about
the map because I don't understand all
that it's too complicated for me I'll
just take the results the conclusions
and I'll deal with then they memorize
that and they say okay black holes dark
matter big bang and and they don't know
how these things came into being yeah
and they just accept the final thing and
they say well the mathematician he's got
a PhD he told me and so I'm just gonna
accept it and that's where the problem
is but because it's to know something is
off you have to delve into the subject
because like let's say you want to learn
how the human body works right
you're not gonna cut a person open and
learn in that way you learn things by
rote
there's we've learned or you learn it
through through second hand you learn
everything that we already know code
unquote yeah so everyone kind of took
that same cookie cutter approach to
learning you know like there's things we
know about chemistry or things that the
general humanity kind of acquired
whatever you want to call it like we
know sodium chloride we can do we can do
certain things if you learn chemistry
you don't have to learn from the ground
up and they kind of took that same
approach to physics or so okay these
guys went off on a tangent you know they
were not fond you know the chemistry
people went down to chemistry tangent so
you just start to learn what they
learned the physics people went off on
physics tangent just learned what they
learned so it's kind of like the same if
they don't see anything wrong because
again to know there's something wrong
chemistry for example you have to go
down that Kevin yeah and see oh hold on
there's there's this is wrong this is
wrong there's details in it that you've
become aware of if you learn it enough
for geology or paleontology the way you
do yeah so it's like you can't really
know something's BS until you go deep in
until you died well you know but the
Indians American Indians assume and so
on you know they would pass that and not
only them but I guess there's a curve
throughout the planet they used to pass
down stories you know they'd sit around
the fire and they would tell stories of
what their forefathers did how did they
learn it well it was passed down from
generation to generation and so now here
was the old man of the tribe or the
senior member or maybe just the father
with son or whatever and he would tell
him the same story that he was told oh
yeah big bear you know a 10,000 years
ago he did this and he was a great man
and did this and this and that and he
would pass that on to his son and now
this son knows the same story and they
would pass it from word of mouth to mind
and now that was you know the son grew
and he was father and now he would pass
it on to his son or to other kids and so
on and and you know the over time I
guess
it got embellished a little you know I
got this story that's changed a little
bit here and there and all the times of
telephone yeah yeah and I guess they
became the forefathers became ever more
like gods over time then he was there
you know this guy was just a normal
human and eventually I guess he went to
Mount Olympus and became like Zeus
because he started having superpowers
after several generations you know and
you get this and and we have a little
bit of that in what you just said you
know the the chemists they went down
this road and they discovered all this
stuff and now you teach it to a new
generation and instead of investigating
say well salt everybody knows I'm not
gonna do salt again these guys did salt
I'll just take whatever they they found
and well what if they did not cover
every base what if they got something
wrong then I'm just memorizing stuff
that I should be memorizing because
nobody decided to scrutinize or
challenged ask the obvious question
right and and so this is where there's a
danger in memorizing sometimes you've
got to do the test again to find out if
they covered every base if they really
came to their senses he goes back to
what we were talking about when we tell
you about old people and young people
words that that traditional sifting
where you have traditions that are
passed down it could also be knowledge
I'm saying call it all traditions things
that generations passed on to the next
generation was in the color tradition
and with traditions is they get passed
down in the past word-of-mouth obviously
because we didn't have any yeah but it's
up to the new generation or one person
in the new generation to kind of cap
cast capture a flaw in the trade a caste
out on it like something like someone
has to pick up like oh something's wrong
here like most of the tradition like
obviously they're not gonna pick up on
emperor has no clothes there's there's
some yeah it's not an old man it's it's
it's always something said now you get
the now you kid who says you know I'm
not biased by anything
the emperor has no clothes and everybody
says shut up but that's the job of the
younger generations to kind of overthrow
the decrepit parts of tribute because
there's obviously most traditions that
have lived this long or useful you'd
think right but there's a few such as
the ones that we harp on so much which
would be physics that one's corrupt like
just up and down but again how do you
how do you know that it's corrupt
another how do you how do you get that
word across the people that there's
something wrong again you have to kind
of delve deep that's why it's a problem
because it's not just a supervision you
can't just come and say look black holes
are irrational well yeah but I don't
know enough to challenge it yeah it's a
serious problem it goes back to that
that many people can't be wrong and what
do I know
yeah yeah that's what he comes that's
when he comes down to Gao just very
simple but it goes but you can say that
about chemistry too I can't walk up to
Aaron at least say I don't think I could
walk up to a chemist and say hey look I
think there's a problem with I don't
know salt the way you guys well you
would have a steady salt on your own and
doing the investigation said and then
compared against the mainstream and then
say oh there's a problem here or at
least there's something I don't
understand and you either get a solution
to the - what you didn't understand or
you challenge the mainstream you say
look you know you guys are wrong here's
both it's when you have a question it
goes unanswered or it gets answered but
you're not satisfied with the answer it
just keeps coming up and come unison
yeah I can know a nun
answer this in a way that satisfies me
am I am I wrong about something or is
the establishment or is there something
I don't understand yeah yeah I think
that's how it works you know when
someone has an inquisitive mind and
there's a question that just keeps not
getting Sam certain order I mean that's
that's what most theologians are about
in question about god that keeps like
poking her in the back yeah it's like
they just they're just not getting that
answer so so it just
but eats at them but most people kind of
just let it go and it happens with all
these dissidents not all of them are
right of course not I mean they have
their own theories and a lot of them
have to do with misunderstanding first
of the mainstream and second of
foundations of physics and so they have
all these different ideas and that's
fine you know everybody believes in
whatever they want to believe but again
it doesn't mean that because you're a
dissident that we should pay attention
to you yeah yeah I have no problem
listening to these people but it doesn't
mean that you're going to accept their
excuse or their version of how things
work because those are more irrational
than the mainstream somebody flat
earthers is they have some questions
that we all kind of take for granted
right which is good because because some
point because they point to the flaws
laws right right and so that no problem
there I have no problem idea of the
electric universe they have a lot of
people who have good arguments against
what exists mathematical physics quantum
mechanics specially general relativity
and so in that sense it's very good to
listen to their version of their
criticism of the of mainstream that's
where it stops you know you don't want
to go into you don't want to go into
what they're proposing is more
irrational thing no no you want to
listen to what I'm saying is it doesn't
mean that because they have a good
argument against the mainstream that
because of that they have a good
alternative that's that's where where
the reasoning fails it doesn't follow it
doesn't follow that because they have
good criticism that they have figured
out how it really works because what
they are proposing is more rational
still but I like the phenomenon of
flat-earthers because I mean many people
just kind of throw them by the wayside
these people are so dumb come on we we
figure this one out
but that sort of mentality is kind of
what goes with what keeps traditions
alive and kills and and prevents the
weeding out of corruption when you say
odd we already answered that question we
don't need to really rediscover that
because yeah we get we got that you know
gravity is is this magnetism is that
just put it under the carpet you know
the world is a ball we're done no no but
you know one of the good things about
things like flat earthers is that you
know I mean you know I can't accept what
they're proposing yeah but what I like
is that you know they make you think in
a different way because they came out of
nowhere and they say look well what
about this you know what about that and
you say ok yeah I see where you're
coming from but it it's an angle that
you won't find in the mainstream because
the maintaining probably would have
never come up with that angle whether
it's rational or not is irrelevant the
point is they come and make you think
from a different angle and and that
focus is it's just interesting and it's
nice to say ok I see you how this guy is
thinking now you know it's it just gives
you a different focus on the problem and
that's in that I think that alone has
valued just that alone yeah what about
the ridicule because I think what what
gets flat earth there is so much riled
up
yeah what gets them right above it is
that no one takes them seriously
alright but that what you have to say
about the offhand ridicule because you
get it all the time
well presenting and no one takes you
seriously just for science sake they
just kind of offhand say it's dumb on to
the next thing
yeah and and again the reason I also
ridicule the establishment is because
that is the circus we have out there in
science I didn't create that circus that
circus was there before I was born and
when you go into so-called science into
physics you know they laugh they laugh
with different ideas ideas that are not
mainstream
this is a problem because you know we
should let everybody just present their
case and if you can laugh at them if you
want but let them present the case but
if you're not gonna let them present
their case and laugh oh no we have a
problem there because now you're
censoring that person and maybe that
person deserves to be laughed at but not
censored don't censor them laugh at them
yeah fine yeah you know say you know you
what you're proposing is ridiculous but
you know we can say that about the
mainstream as well I mean black holes
Big Bang creationism dark matter
particles of mass I mean that is
ridiculous all of that is ridiculous and
so you know but you're not allowed to
ridicule them but they are allowed to
censor and ridicule you and so that's
that's uh we don't have a level playing
field or the dumbest yeah and the people
who are the smartest are full of doubt
and part of that has to do with the fact
that we memorize in in school we just
memorize and then we become dumb because
we say well you know it's already been
proven and we don't even question it and
that's where that's a big danger there
anyways Bertrand Russell okay anyways
you know I I did define the word
irrational and I have four criteria for
that and there are the conversion of
concepts into objects using undefined
words or using them inconsistently then
the theory doesn't follow from the
assumptions and the last one I that I
have included recently is to describe
and claim that you are explaining okay
and that fourth one you know that's
quite popularly in mathematical physics
at physics today they claim that they
can explain for example
man networks they say how a magnet works
and they have not explained it they just
described that positive attracts
negative north attract south and south
reject south that's all they're telling
you and the same thing you know when
they say you know the moon doesn't drift
out of the solar system because there's
a gravity well a depression in
space-time but what are they using
they're using the concept field or the
concept gravity wheel or the concept
space-time and that's not an explanation
again you know when you take a concept
and use it as a physical object what
you're doing is really doing it in
Reverse you're not explaining what
you're doing really is describing using
this concept and twisting it around say
oh I have explained so all I'm saying is
that fourth one is has been added I've
added that recently and I'm saying you
know to describe something and claim
that you have explained it shows first
you don't know the difference between a
description and an explanation and
second that it is not an explanation you
know you haven't explained how the
magician did the trick all you did was
you know describe what happened on stage
well how something works could have two
interpretations I think the question is
remote control work yes the buttons yeah
but all right I could also mean how does
it remote control work what are the
intricacies the electric components that
make it work yeah and and this is where
the problem and that's why they confuse
description with explanation right right
and so this is the problem people think
that they have explained or that they
understood the mechanism but they're not
dealing with mechanism they're just
dealing with a description you know to
say how does gravity work and you say
well you know the pen falls at 9.8
meters per second squared
well you haven't explained any all you
did was you know describe it
mathematically you know the speed at
which the pen falls to the floor it
doesn't you haven't explained the
mechanism why goes down to the floor
instead of the ceiling and so you know
we have to separate these things and
that's not clear when you go through
like if you go through YouTube you'll
find a lot of people saying how magnets
work and what they never none of them do
is explain how magnets work in other
words yeah how in the sense North
attracts South that's not a how in the
sense of an explanation that's just a
description and if you can't distinguish
between the explanation and description
then I'm saying then you know you've got
an irrational explanation because you
substituted explanation description for
an explanation and so okay so those are
the criteria for irrationality so there
is an objective criteria that I'm
proposing and those people who don't
like it it's because you know I'm
touching their religion fine no problem
you don't like it you tell me what you
mean by rational give me an objective
definition of rational or irrational and
that's where they all run away they say
you know I don't deal with that but see
they want to consider themselves
rational without defining the term
rational and and that's unacceptable in
science that's okay you know ordinary
speech but not in something you know
yeah and again I made a point also in
the article there on Quora that and my
son beat me up so much on that that I
had to concede it's not that you're
treating the person as irrational that
might follow you might conclude that
indirectly or extrapolating or whatever
but the point is that when you use the
word irrational or rational in a
scientific way you're not referring to
the person you're referring to the
theory you're saying look is objectively
is this theory rational and then you go
through all these criteria and say no it
fails this criteria you're using a
concept as an object you're you haven't
defined this term and or you used it
inconsistently your theory doesn't
follow from the hypothesis your
explanation doesn't follow from your
assumptions that sort of thing and you
do it objectively and you say that the
theory is irrational or rational for
that matter and not the person but you
know it's like everybody takes it
personally and saying
he's criticizing me now I'm criticizing
your theory okay so the word irrational
ration should be applied to theories
anyways I have defined also the word
knowledge and my son still has an action
item he will deliberate I think at the
end of the year so it says knowledge the
ability to predict the outcome of an
experiment without error that's my
definition of knowledge in again but
what if it happens to have no error did
you know them yeah but see the point is
that we don't know that before you run
the experiment that's yeah if you run
the experiment you knew and if you run
the experiment and it comes out wrong
you were guessing then no no Dan you
don't know but no but that means that
you can't say in retrospect that I knew
but you said the definition is running
the ability to predict it's there you
could just read it there I predict that
this pen will fall to the floor you drop
it happens then hit the floor
I knew forget any conceit any next
experiments but at that time I knew you
guessed I'm saying you go well no I can
say you guessed okay and you say well
why because I'm saying well you did not
know you you were you were betting you
placed your bet did you really know did
you I mean I can guess to you know many
things and it just turns out that I
guessed right for this specific
experiment did I know or did I guess no
no how can you distinguish those two no
no one does because I'm saying that no
no because again and I'm saying that you
can't distinguish nouns from guests and
if you guessed assuming
right there that you guess something
like you know I've got a voice listener
I've got a quote if you throw a dime
right and a half an SMS it's gonna come
up five yeah and it happens to come on
five right did you know or did you just
guess I mean we all can guess according
to your definition I knew then I
predicted the outcome and it was without
error
yeah but see the issue is that if you
did not get it then you guessed but if I
do what you can't distinguish between no
the issue is that you can't distinguish
between knowledge and gifts no it's not
it's not because I'm saying that all
knowledge is guess all of it yeah I mean
we can replace the word now it's with
guests and and you would not be able to
change that yeah yeah but I guess I'm
just and tell me what the difference is
because one is with their or without
error
and the other one is without here one is
either or you can say anything and and
knowledge is you do the test and it just
happens to be right according to your
definition so you know yeah but don't
put the only in that van easy thank you
clearly speaking if if you were right we
don't know if you were if you knew her
guest if you were wrong you guessed yeah
but then you didn't know that but my
point you don't you don't understand so
you still don't understand the
definition in advance you cannot know
because we don't even have to run the
test it's not a question of saying let's
run the test and see if I knew no no we
don't even get to run the test because
you will not be able to predict without
error predict not do the experiment but
predict it you can't you know you can't
that's the point
we don't get to run the test ever yeah
we never get to the point half the
no no because he no no because we're
talking about prediction that about
running experience nowhere does it say
it or run the experiment have to run you
can yeah and I can prove to me that you
can predict the outcome of an experiment
without error show me show me before we
run any experiment Dana you will no no
you tell me no you gotta give me an
experience you dumb in I'll give you a
prediction no you can't give me a
prediction now that matter without one
with no you okay dropping your pen
letting letting go of a pen or what will
happen tell me without error yeah yeah
the pen will go up that was a prediction
the pen will go up yeah that was a
prediction and all you're saying is and
you without error
are you sure that yeah yeah without
Aaron you're saying why will they go up
I mean without running experiment tell
me why it will go up it doesn't say why
no no but I'm saying you can't predict
because I'm saying you're wrong just had
to predict yeah but nothing right nobody
without areas he is right but then you
have to run the experiment no you don't
you have that's the point the point is
you never get to run the experiment
because you cannot guarantee to me but
you cannot guarantee debatably knows but
then all we're saying is I can know
something but you can't know if I know
you can't be sure that I know right and
nygel knowledge is what you prove to
someone else yeah yeah yeah without no
but I got predicted to myself yeah yeah
yeah you could be your own audience no
problem it can be the only game right
yeah and you proved to yourself no I
don't prove no no that's what knowledge
is without the air well it's without air
oh how guaranteed to yourself that
you're gonna do it without air please
show me I guarantee in here yeah it is
it says without error it says it's gotta
be without error now show me you don't
have to this is my point you don't have
to be sure that it's gonna
be without error yes you do because it
says the ability to do without their
whether someone knows is without error
or not is besides the point huh whether
someone knows that it is without error
is besides the point that's not in here
I don't know what you're saying okay and
what's your argument whether someone
knows yeah it's actually true whether
it's without a definition of knowledge
do it now without error
yeah there's no one who can looking who
can say that it is without error or not
right you cannot guarantee whatever
prediction you made you don't need a
guarantee yes you do it says without
error yeah but no one has to know that
is without error that's money and you
have to know you know you know yourself
to yourself know why because say because
it says without err yeah but let's say
for the sake of argument to the sake of
our UI saying if I drop a pain it's
gonna go up right okay and that happened
not that we're gonna do and you gara
know hold on hold on yeah and mother
nature you know some goes that you know
the way we use mother nature the one who
actually knows right air pulls it up no
no no okay mother nature is the person
who actually knows right what's gonna
happen for sure no wrong that's my
assumption hello you know no no no no no
even mother nature not even God knows
what's gonna happen in the future that's
the point
not even theoretically not even
theoretically that's that's what the
definition is all about saying you don't
even have to run the test
not even mother nature knows what's
gonna happen next why would she know
theoretically speaking yeah something's
gonna happen
yeah theoretically speaking it we had it
goes that new why was that why would it
irrelevant why no no why would mother
nature know that's relevant
no no but at the other to my point
that's irrelevant to my point okay
what's your point I just I just need to
establish a referee that knows what's
gonna actually happen regardless of what
I would then remember II no no no but
what do you
a referee who's the referee we and
mother nature God how would they know
that's irrelevant no no it is relevant I
want to know how they why are you
selecting numbers of referee that's I'm
getting to that
okay please do you have a god yeah yeah
oh god yeah god you can't tell me that
what's gonna happen communication he's
just somewhere so so let's say he's the
referee that knows exactly what's gonna
happen without error no no no no hold it
at that part I know that how are you
gotta clarify why why why would why
would he be a wrestler a referee why
would he know that's irrelevant
no no if you're gonna select them as a
referee in it is relevant poison rather
because I'm saying not even got our
mother nature nobody knows what's gonna
happen next
I'm saying anywhere near Emily you're
saying it's radically but you're saying
it's irrational to even even ponder the
question that someone can know the
future right not a human being and talk
about a supernatural being anybody why
is that
why can't you even block you know the
block universe the future has already
happened yeah well that's that's the
point the point is that the point is
that if it's already happened it's the
past it's not the future anymore
you can't even postulate a supernatural
being
no no because then you have to postulate
you don't even have to postulate a
supernatural being all you have to do is
postulate the block universe and we're
done which is supernatural yeah you
could say can we start there no because
because then we have a contradiction
right there and then that the block
universe means it's already happened the
future is the past so we're not talking
about the few I'm talking about
predicting the future not about the past
anybody can predict the past the only
way dr. Brady it's already half done
literally there's no such thing as the
future so the right point is moot anyway
right and that's my point that's the
point of the word now it's that the
future has not happened so the only way
you would know nobody is if if it's a
black finish let me finish the only way
you would know exactly without error
that that the pen is going to fall to
the floor or whatever is if it's already
to past and you're just essentially
regurgitating what's already happened
the block the universe but the whole
point is moot if you can't even talk
about prediction because there's no
future correct but that's my point by
the word another it's it's it's more or
less the same argument as saying that
you know that Napoleon went of water you
don't know because you can't reproduce
the experiments so what you're talking
about is really explaining not or
describing but not about knowing this is
something similar but applied to the
future you can't know the future you
can't predict the future because to
predict it without error means it's
already happened then only then can you
do it but then you have a contradiction
in that it's the past that you're yeah
that you know for sure that happened
what about assuming the future that's
different assuming is different than
knowing but is that what people mean
because they go assuming I mean there's
a whole bunch of unspoken assumptions
anytime we're talking right yeah but
when I say the dominoes are going to hit
each other and the fourth time I was
gonna fall over for example that's a
prediction and the it's really more of
an assumption saying assuming you know
nothing weird happens right I mean yes a
set of assumptions but you don't say my
loud that's the that's the tricky part
when you're predicting they're implied
there there's a lot of implied he goes
back to the to the to the what do you
call shooting the racehorses analogies
were the assumption the implicit
assumptions are assuming nothing weird
happened right
yeah again and and that's why I'm saying
you can't predict unless you know all
the in fact uh you know you had what was
the name French guy who who said you
know if he knew all these variables out
there everything that you know if he
knew the movement of every single atom
in the universe then he could predict
the future he could do that but Ron's
was it yeah I think it was look Ron
anyways uh he he said you know he could
predict if he knew all the variables he
knew everything that was going on
like for example Mother Nature would
know everything that's going on every
atom how it's moving everything you're
thinking so she knows has all that
information then you can't fool her she
knows exactly what's gonna happen next
why'd you [ __ ] on my supernatural being
was that one allowed no no all I'm
saying is this is what I think it was I
was saying he was saying you know if I
had or if I knew all these variables and
knew everything you're thinking and
everything that everybody's thinking I
have full knowledge of all the variables
and all the movement of every atom in
the universe
and all the thoughts that are being
created then I could predict the next
you know what's gonna happen without
error without you know I would say
that's true if you're not part of that
universe if you yourself are not can I
get to the ropes god you don't know
because if you're part of it then you
can change conversation for different
okay now you're you're literally moving
your arm so you're changing it but then
you know you're gonna move your arm so I
guess yes you know it goes back to the
question can God see what he's gonna do
next right but that's but that's why if
you take yourself out of you know
assuming all the atoms are connected by
ropes and everything if you have this
cluster of rope or thread that will call
that the universe okay and you're
outside of it assuming you could see it
or whatever yeah
you only have to see it but assuming you
know everything that's going on in that
cluster then yeah I think you could
predict everything except that we have a
variable which is what people think you
can't really do that well you know
that's a little more difficult to and
then that is for a long argument the
fact that you know if you if you you
know if God knows exactly what you're
thinking
well maybe he can predict that
everything right but he would have to
know not only the mechanical stuff
how matter is moving and how fast and
all that how much things weigh but on
top of that he knows what you're
thinking and that you might change
course and say oh instead of going left
I'm gonna go right but just imagine that
for a second God knows exactly what he's
gonna do next
he knows the future right well that's
kind of weird because imagine God
knowing exactly what he's gonna do next
and then he knows exactly what he's
gonna do next and what he's gonna do
next what he's gonna do now no no but
just let me follow this train of thought
and I'm saying that if God knows what
he's gonna do next and he knows he he
can't avoid it you know he's gonna know
free will assuming God is outside of the
universe outside of that about him
outside of the things that he knows
basically no no but I mean not talking
about himself he's a you know that's
what I was talking about if God knows
what he's gonna do next thing it gets
weird yeah it does I mean that's what
I'm saying it's a saying I can't avoid
it because I know there are sting words
or la plage if you're not part of the
University you know because then it gets
weird yeah you have to be outside of the
universe cluster and then again why
would you know what the guy is thinking
oh that's right yeah and you're talking
more in Supernatural tell you something
impossible I don't think I'd imagine
I'll do your brain can hold them
and so you know again I reject the word
knowledge from science I don't think
there is such a thing as now this
anyways science deals with explanation
doesn't deal with knowledge anyway so in
a way it's a mood issue why did you love
assumptions which is the next best thing
yeah does deal with assumptions but
primarily you know we're everywhere yeah
but remember science vibrates in
explanations in theory that's where it
really vibrates but the assumptions are
important obviously you need assumptions
before you go in to say efficacy in
physics right anyways we're gonna
continue this tomorrow we got a couple I
can't seem to get to quantum even though
I think I want to show that you know
quantum is a ranch I've been trying to
show this for the last three days but I
can't seem to get there but hopefully we
yeah one for yesterday definitions to
objective versus subjective and today I
wanted to put irrationality for quantum
but I gotta change this one as well I'll
do that tomorrow
if my son lets me and otherwise I'll
have to overrule them beat them up you
know and we get them hit them with my
buddy rail tracks we'll see you tomorrow
and thank God you know the technology
worked we'll see you tomorrow same time
same station see you that bye bye